oh hey none of this news we're learning
new details about the terrifying crash
of a Boeing 737 into a Florida River the
military charter jet carrying a hundred
and forty three people skidded off the
runway Friday and ran into the st. Johns
River everyone aboard survived the plane
took off from Guantanamo Bay Cuba and
was landing at Naval Air Station
Jacksonville Kris Van Cleave is near the
scene with the scary experience for the
passengers Chris good morning well good
morning the plane is still in the water
you can see it there almost frozen in
time from that moment of the evacuation
severe weather kept investigators off
the water yesterday and they're still
trying to figure out just why this
landing went so wrong cell phone video
shows some of the 143 onboard the Miami
air charter flight Friday night huddled
on the wing of the 737 waiting for
rescue almost sounded like an explosion
it was just a loudest crash I've ever
heard in my life
passenger Darwyn Silva shot this video
after he opened one of the emergency
exits and helped people escape it was
total chaos those total mayhem heard
children crying I heard people screaming
by boat we got a closer look the
over-wing exits Silva used sit open and
look here an exit slide is floating
still attached the plane is sitting in
four to six feet of water and
investigators say it came to rest on a
rock bet of course one of the real
challenges is how do you get a 737 out
of a river investigators need to do that
in part because the cockpit voice
recorder is submerged the NTSB says the
pilots changed their landing approach to
a different runway preliminary flight
data shows the plane appeared to come in
with a tailwind and fast around 205
miles per hour with one engine thrust
reverser off line the thrust reverser
would help slow the plane down if it was
working properly
it could yes Bruce Landsberg is the vice
chairman of the NTSB it is quite
remarkable that everyone walked away
from this accident it is remarkable
we've been involved in a number of other
investigations where the outcome wasn't
so positive
Silva realizes this and says he's
grateful to be home with his sons there
my motivation for everything and I knew
I had to get a taxi to wait
for them 22 people suffered minor
injuries they're all expected to be okay
and the forecast is improving that
should help investigators but they
expect the plane will be in the water
for at least the next few days John
Chris thank you